[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous
présente le club des
territoires et avec nous pour ce club
cine Verzeletti bonjour merci d'être
avec nous secrétaire confédéral de la
CGT Marc ferci bonjour merci d'être là
député renaissance des Français établis
hors de France on va parler des salaires
et du pouvoir d'achat préoccup majeure
des Français une grande conférence
sociale réunissant syndicat patronat et
gouvernement avaient lieu hier les
pistes sont elles les bonnes le
gouvernement répondil suffisamment
l'inquiétude des Français vous nous
direz ce que vous en pensez Alex avec
vous on va voir plus clair sur les
chiffres oui on verra par exemple
pourquoi les femmes sont moins bien payé
que les hommes ou pourquoi certaines
branches professionnelles ont des
salaires minimum inférieurs au SMIC et
on commence tout de suite le débat de ce
[Musique]
club
et avant de vous entendre on est allé à
la rencontre des Français face à une
inflation galopante ils sont de plus en
plus nombreux à chercher des solutions
pour continuer à remplir leur CAD appli
antigaspi en scène de Hard disccount les
moyens sont nombreux mais de plus en
plus prisé on regarde ce reportage de
Mathias
SZ parfois on la voit bien la
différence surtout au passage à la
caisse Antonio est à la chasse aux
bonnes affaires dans cette enseigne de
hardisount je prends m beaucoup dans le
magasin aussi comme beaucoup ce
chauffeur routier de 30 ans a vu son
pouvoir d'achat fondre comme neige au
soleil ces derniers mois tout augmente
sauf le salaire quoi donc et euh bon on
est un peu force saler toujours un peu
moins cher on va dire mais ça vra que on
a un peu la qualité avec le prix qui
reste qui reste très raisonnable ici
quoi alimentaire boissons produits
d'hygiène en grand conditionnement les
allées de ce magasin regorgent de
référence en dessous du prix du marché
au moins 30 % des minimum sur l'hygiène
l'alimentaire aussi et le reste 20 20 %
à peu près une politique de prix rendue
possible par une baisse des marges et
qui forcément fait augmenter la
fréquentation mais les magasins de
hardiscount ne sont pas les seuls prix
d'assaut ces derniers mois selon une
étude récente depuis le début de
l'inflation 8 Français sur 10 ont
adoptés des comportements antiaspillage
alimentaire c'est le cas d'Aurélia grâce
à une application cette jeun active
récupère des paniers de produits frais
avec une date limite de consommation
proche cou aujourd'hui j'ai du lait des
yaourts euh de la viande un peu de
poisson euh il y a aussi une
salade un
sandwich au fond et des plats préparés
si la lutte contre le gaspillage est
importante pour la jeune femme l'aspect
économique reste primordial c'est sûr
que la première c'est l'argent ça coûte
moins cher voilà on gagne là j'ai payé
3,99 € un panier qui en vaut plus de 12
€ même quand on est actif ce genre de
petite astuce ça permet de gagner en
pouvoir d'achat donc c'est pas
négligeable avec une inflation globale
avoisinant les 5 % toutes les solutions
sont bonnes pour s'en sortir en mai
dernier l'Ifop estimait que plus d'un
Français sur deux sautait régulièrement
ou aucun occasionnellement un repas par
manque d'argent c'estine verti on voit
c'est français dans les magasins de
hardis ce sont des Français qui
travaillent dans des magasins de
hardiscount chercher des applis pour
lutter contre l'inflation est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui les Français sont
résignés face à la vie chè alors
résignés je ne sait pas quoi qu'il en
soit c'est une vraie problématique vous
l'avez dit on le voit parce que
finalement ça ça impacte vraiment les
conditions de vie d'une grande partie de
la population c'est-à-dire que c'est un
problème pour pour manger correctement
alors je ne parle même pas le de le le
fait que on ne puisse plus aller soit en
vacances soit profiter d'activités
culturelles soit pouvoir aussi se
chauffer correctement enfin voilà c'est
c'est vraiment des on va dire des des
choses élémentaires qu' qu'on ararrive
plus à avoir moi je précise quand même
que il y a euh 50 % des salariés qui
touchent moins de 2000 € par mois et
aujourd'hui pour vivre correctement
justement il faut plus de 2000 € par
mois d'ailleurs nous nous av des
revendications avec un SMIC à 2000 € par
mois justement donc là on voit bien
qu'il y a il y a une
problématique laquelle ne veut pas
traiter le gouvernement parce que on va
parler de cette question des salaires
gouvernement tout ce qui est salaire
c'est hors de son radar et c'est une
vraie problématique mais juste avant la
la question des salaires Bruno Lemire
dit que l'inflation c'est son combat
numéro 1 est-ce que le gouvernement en
fait assez pour aider ces Français
contre la vie chè et ben dans les
derniers mois le gouvernement la
majorité présidentielle ont pris éément
de décisions qui ont protégé quoi qu'on
veuill en dire le pouvoir d'achat des
Français en agissant sur les prix le
pouvoir d'achat c'est la combinaison de
deux facteurs c'est le prix des produits
que vous achetez et c'est les revenus
que vous avez qui peuvent être composés
du salaire mais pas uniquement du
salaire il y a d'autres éléments on va
sans doute en parler et ce qu'on a fait
depuis maintenant plus d'un an et demi
et bien c'est de protéger le pouvoir
d'achat des Français avec des boucliers
énergétiques avec des boucliers
tarifaires et quand on regarde ce qui se
passe en France par rapport à ce qui se
passe dans les autres pays en terme
d'inflation on voit que la France est le
pays qui s'en sort le mieux alors ça
veut pas dire qu'il y a pas des des des
personnes qui sont dans la difficulté
votre reportage l'a bien montré il y a
énormément de Français qui aujourd'hui
peineent à remplir leur cadit peine à
acheter les choses élémentaires dont
parle madame Verzeletti et ça il faut
continuer d'agir là-dessus mais je pense
que il faut quand même pas entre
guillemets négliger ce qui a été fait il
faut se projeter un petit peu dans
l'avenir on va parler de la conférence
sociale mais moi je considère quand même
que beaucoup de choses ont été faites
depuis maintenant plus d'un an il y a
quand même des choses qui ont été faites
c'est non maisors alors il y a des
choses qui ont été faites ça on peut pas
le nier à part que nous nous pensons que
justement ce qui a été fait euh ne ne
n'est pas euh ne sont pas des solutions
pérennes pour faire face à cette
inflation qui reste dans la durée en
fait donc vous dites vous parler des des
boucliers des des primes des des des
choses qui permettent pour un temps en
fait voilà d'échec ça ce sont des
solutions qui sont provisoires nous on
le voit et je pense que tous les
économistes le disent l'inflation elle
est vraiment dans la durée donc pour
préserver dans la durée le pouvoir
d'achat euh de la population il n'y a
pas 50 solutions la première c'est
véritablement d'augmenter les salaires
et je dirais que c'est pour préserver le
pouvoir d'achat par rapport à
l'inflation mais aussi pour qu'il y ait
une vraie reconnaissance des
qualifications des compétences et de
l'expérience des salariés et ça c'est
pareil on a beaucoup beaucoup perdu et
je dirais que le gouvernement a une
grande responsabilité parce que vous le
savez il y a 5 millions d' gent dans la
fonction publique et là les
augmentations de salaires dépendent bien
donc du gouvernement et on refuse le
gouvernement refuse d'augmenter
significativement la rémunération de ces
fonctionnaires qui ont eux et chiffre à
l'appui ont un pouvoir d'achat qui ne
cesse de baisser aussi et les salariés
du privé qui malheureusement eux aussi
donc ont des salaires qui finalement
baissent puisque les prix augmentent et
que leur salaire stag Marc fer je vous
laisse répondre sur la question des
fonctionnaires et après on va parler de
la conférence d'abord dire que dire que
la rémunération des fonctionnaires et le
point d'indice a évolué quand même ces
derniers ces derniers mois euh ensuite
en dessous de l'inflation une
augmentation de 1 3 alors que avz une
inflation de 5 est-ce que le point
d'indice avait évolué dans les dernières
années non on a tenu comp on a tenu
compte on a tenu compte de la situation
et en particulier de cette inflation qui
frappe tout le monde et compris les
fonctionnaires maintenant euh la
question de fond c'est est-ce que c'est
à l'État d'augmenter les salaires des
salariés du secteur privé qui sont quand
même plus nombreux que les
fonctionnaires euh la conviction qu'on a
dans la majorité présidentielle c'est
que c'est par le dialogue social qu'on
arrive à augmenter les salaires au
niveau des branches surtout au niveau
des entreprise et dans la rémunération
qui tend send le pouvoir d'achat il y a
pas que le salaire il y a aussi d'autres
éléments vous avez dit que il y a des
éléments de prime qui peuvent intervenir
nous on assume face à un choc qui est
quand même un choc ponctuel moi je le
dis l'inflation les prévisions le disent
elle va quand même ralentir et c'est une
bonne chose dans les prochains mois
d'ailleurs l'INC explique que d'ici la
fin de l'année le pouvoir d'achat va
augmenter le pouvoir d'achat des
Français va augmenter de plus d'1 %
est-ce que ça va se concrétiser je
l'espère mais en tout état de cause on
avait un choc qui était quand même assez
ponctuel qui était lié à la guerre en
Ukraine qui était lié au contexte
géopolitique au prix du pétrole au prix
des matériaux de construction bref on
avait besoin de mesures d'urgence et
c'est pour ça que la logique de prime de
soutien au pouvoir d'achat au soutien au
revenu qui est passé notamment par le
projet de loi partage de la valeur qui
est examiné ces jours-ci au Sénat et
bien elle avait sa logique à un moment
quand on a quelque chose qui qui
intervient de manière brutale et bien il
faut avoir des réponses d'urgence vous
parlez des salaires moi je voudrais
juste vous dire une chose et pour pas
être plus long c'est que à un moment ou
un autre lorsque l'on augmente les
salaires sans tenir compte et bien de ce
que peuvent faire les entreprises
notamment les plus petites d'entre elles
et bien ça a une conséquence ça c'est
direct c'est qu'on détruit des emplois
alors on peut ne pas se préoccuper de ça
mais la réalité c'est que augmenter les
salaires de manière massive de manière
inconsidérée sans tenir compte de la
situation des entreprises et bien ça
peut avoir des conséquences très
dommageables alors ça c'est toujours ce
qu'on nous répond hein c'est-à-dire que
le coût du travail serait trop élevé
donc du coup il ne faut pas augmenter
les salaires ou il ne faut pas que les
salaires soient trop importants à part
que nous c'est pas ce que nous
constatons c'est que le coût du capital
augmente d'année en année et le coût du
travail baisse de plus en plus donc ça
c'est le la le partage des richesses qui
pose question et qui doit poser débat
par contre ce que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure c'est que le gouvernement l'état
euh n'est n'est n'est pas là pour
augmenter les les salaires des des des
salariés des travailleurs du privé à
part que ce que nous nous constatons
c'est que l'État par contre octroit des
aides publiques des aides publiques aux
entreprises privées à hauteur à peu près
de 200 milliards d'euros par an ces
aides publiques elles sont censées en
partie être octroyé aux entreprises pour
que ces entreprisesl créent de l'emploi
c'est ce qui est dit ce sont donc les
arguments à part que ce qu'on constate
c'est que par rapport à ces aides
publiques qui sont donc très importantes
il y a très peu d'emplois de créer donc
ça veut bien dire que non non mais ça
veut dire que c'est pour ça que nousous
demandons des
conditionnalités à C ces aides qui je le
dis elles sont versées sans aucune
contrepartie ça veut dire que des
grandes entreprises des multinationales
perçoivent ces aides alors même qu'elle
ne n'augmente pas les salaires qu'elle
n'investissent pas ni dans la richesse
ni dans la richesse pardon ni dans
l'emploi et par contre ce qu'on constate
c'est que les dividendes versés aux
actionnaires augmentent et les profits
augment et les marges dégagées
augmentent alors même que ces
entreprises là donc ça c'est sur le dos
de de l'État et c'est donc l'impôt qui
PES a si vous le permettez moi je suis
d'accord pour regarder les effets des
aides sur l'emploi c'est d'ailleurs ce
que j'ai fait puisque j'ai remis avec
mon collègue parlementaire député Jérôme
GED un rapport à la commission des
affaires sociales pour évaluer les
effets des exonérations de cotisation
social et on parvient à la conclusion
que certaines exonérations notamment
cell qui porte sur les haut salaires
entre 2,5 3,5 donc entre 4 6000 € elles
ne sont pas efficaces en terme de
création d'emploi et on propose de les
supprimer on propose de les supprimer
dans ce rapport et puisque vous évoquez
la conditionnalité de ces exonérations
il y a pas que les
exonérations mais il y a notamment les
exonérations qui représentent à peu près
75 milliards d'euros c'est quand même
des sommes très considérabl euh
s'agissant de la conditionnalité là
aussi on fait un rapport transpartisan
Jérôme gu est député socialiste moi je
suis député de la majorité on s'est mis
d'accord on est arrivé à la conclusion
commune selon laquelle conditionner les
exonérations de cotisation sociale à à
des objectifs notamment de négociation
salariale de négociation salariale dans
les branches ça n'était pas une bonne
idée pourquoi parce que vous avez
d'abord un problème d'équité et a un
problème juridique comment vous traitez
deux entreprises dans la même branche
dont l'une respecte la convention
collective dont les minimas sont en
dessous du SMIC et donc dont l'une a des
salaires très faibles tous tassés au
niveau du SMIC et l'autre qui est mieux
disante et qui est plus généreuse avec
ses salariés vous supprimez les
exonérations à ces deux entreprises B
non c'est pas logique donc à un moment
il faut avoir conscience de ce qu'il est
possible de faire je constate que ce est
revenu sur la table lors de la
conférence sociale mais de manière un
petit peu différente et moi ce que je
pense c'est qu'à un moment un autre il
faut évaluer les choses et à partir du
moment où les allègements de cotisation
sociale créent des emplois et c'est le
cas c'est le cas quand elles sont
centrées sur les bas
salaires ça
oui combien vous évaluez ces créations
d'emploi vous augmentz le coût du
travail au niveau du SMIC de 10 % vous
détruisez 10 % des des emplois au niveau
du SMIC non non mais c'est c'est pas moi
qui dis c'est des diaines vous AZ empné
alors vous AZ 200 milliards c'est
énormez millions de salariés vous avez 2
millions de salariés au niveau du SMIC
si vous considérreer que vous allez
reprendre 10 % 10 points d'exonération
aux entreprises au niveau du SMIC ça
veut dire que vous augmentez de 10 % le
coût du travail et ça veut dire
concrètement que vous allez détruire
tout de suite dans les mois qui viennent
l'équivalent de 200000 emplois est-ce
que vous voulez faire ça nous on ne veut
pas faire ça on n'est pas des apprentis
sorciers et on ne touche pas à un coût
du travail qui est déjà très élevé par
rapport trè non il est il est en tout
cas il baissez paste des
exontionante baisse le coût du travail
par rapport au coût du capital je le dis
et les CHR expliquez-moi expliquez-moi
ce que vous entendez par coup du capital
parce que c'est une notion qui est pas
aussi simple que celle de C du ok
très bien les dividendes versés aux
actionnaires elles ont augmenté en
France elles ont augmenté pour moi ça
c'est la rémunération du capital oui et
bien c'est ça fait partie du coût du
capital comme quand on parle de la
rémunération des salariés ça fait partie
du coût du travail et bien les
dividendes vers aux actionnaires je suis
désolé ça fait partie du coup du capital
alors qu'est-ce que vous comptez dans le
capre des emplois et puisque vous parlez
des travailleurs pauvres on les a vu les
travailleurs pves dans ce
reportage50% Audi aujourd'hui on sait
que la pauvreté elle a deux causes
principales soit le non emploi le fait
de pas avoir d'emploi du tout soit le
sous-emploi c'est-à-dire le fait de ne
pas travailler suffisamment et de ne pas
être rémunéré suffisamment que mais
effet on joue aux apprentis sorciers et
que en augmentant le coût du travail de
manière massive on des emplois et bien
on génère de manière massive de la
pauvreté c'est une
réité un point sur lequel vous êtes pas
d'accord c'est l'indexation des salaires
sur l'inflation vous c'est ce que vous
demandez pour vous c'est pas une bne
idée ça n'est pas une bonne idée et je
suis pas le seul à le penser c'est ce
qui a été annoncé hier lors de la
conférence social on nira pas dans cette
direction là à la fois parce que ça va
détruire des emplois il y a des
entreprises qui ne seruront pas suivre
et aussi parce que c'est susceptible de
créer de l'inflation à travers une
spirale les salaires augmentent donc les
prix augmentent et donc les salaires
augmentent Enour oui non mais c'est ce
qui est dit à part que nous ce qu'on
constate c'est que les prix augmentent
les salaires n'augmentent pas et les
profits augmentent donc quand vous dites
boucle prix salaire moi je dis boucle
prix profit et en fait c'est ce qu'on
constate il y a eu des éléments en effet
vous les avez cité tout à l'heure qui
ont fait qu'il y avait une inflation
aujourd'hui c'est plus tout à fait le
cas on constate que les prix com
continuent à augmenter pour justement
continuer à augmenter les profits des
entreprises et là donc c'est bien une
boucle prix profit et nous ça nous le
contestons après moi je le redis quand
vous dites augmenter les prix ça serait
finalement un manque d'attractivité il y
aurait moins d'emplois moi je pense que
non au contraire vous l'avez dit on est
en train de le dire les salariés ne
peuvent pas en fait consommer
correctement puisqu'ils ont un pouvoir
d'achat qui est de plus en plus bas et
ils le disent il peuvent même pas se
mourir correctement si demain vous
augmentez les salaires ils vont ils vont
consommer différemment et ils vont
pouvoir mieux vivre et en même temps ça
crée de l'emploi puisquils consomme plus
un point sur les chiffres avant de vous
laisser répondre Marti Alex oui car ça
peut paraître étonnant vu la difficulté
actuelle de certains Français mais pour
la première fois depuis 2021 depuis
quelques mois la hausse des salaires est
en train de rattraper la hausse des prix
le salaire mensuel de base c'est-à-dire
sans les primes sans les exonérations et
bien au 2è trimestre 2023 a augmenté de
4,6 % sur 1 an alors que les prix ont
augmenté de 4,4 % donc si on prend en
compte les effets de l'inflation et bien
ce salaire mensuel de base est rester
plutôt stable à plus 0,2 %. c'est une
hausse qui n'est pas homogène en
fonction des différentes catégorie
d'emploi on peut dire que le salaire
mensuel des employés des ouvriers a
légèrement augmenté ces derniers mois
alors que celui des professions
intermédiaires et des cadres a un peu
baissé au vu de l'inflation alors ces
chiffres qui sont légèrement optimiste
et bien sûr il ne compense pas les
pertes de pouvoir d'achat des Français
ces deux dernières années oui vous avez
raison première conclusion et
enseignement de ce que vous venez de
dire c'est à nouveau par la négociation
le dialogue social dans les entreprises
et dans les branches que les salaires
con connaisse une dynamique et un moment
un autre il faut se ramener à cette
réalité ensuite vous l'avez dit très
justement c'est pas homogène il y a des
gens qui ne perçoivent pas ces
augmentation de salaire en tout cas qui
ne perçoivent pas une légère
amélioration du pouvoir d'achat qui
pourrait intervenir et à ces gens-là il
faut apporter des réponses moi je pense
que ce qui a été dit hier lors de la
conférence sociale ce sont des éléments
assez importants il faut qu'on se mette
d'accord déjà sur l'existence de
phénomènes qui font que les salaires
n'augmentent pas assez autour du SMIC en
particulier on le voir il y a plein de
salariés modestes qui sont au SMIC
pendant toute une partie de leur
carrière professionnelle et qui restent
à proximité du SMIC pendant toute leur
vie professionnelle ça il faut apporter
des réponses à
ça qui été apporté c'est déjà de
regarder de manière un peu un peu
méthodique la manière dont les salaires
sont déterminés aujourd'hui jusqu'à 1,5
SMIC vous avez droit à la prime
d'activité par exemple peut-être que il
y a pas beaucoup d'incitations à
augmenter les salariés parce que si vous
les augmentez au-udessus de 1,5 SMIC et
ben ils perdent la prime d'activité la
première ministre ministre a annoncé
qu'un comité allait se pencher dans les
prochains mois sur les interactions
entre les exonérations de charge Chelle
et la prime d'activité j'espère qu'il en
sortira quelque chose il y a un autre
élément qui moi me paraît très important
c'est que un moment pour aller négocier
son salire avec son patron et bien il
vaut mieux avoir des qualifications des
compétences et être plus productif c'est
aussi comme ça qu'on obtient des
augmentations de salaire il y a un
impensé il y a un grand absent dans ce
débat sur les salaires c'est la
productivité et donc la compétence et
donc la qualification moi je suis pour
et bien qu'on réfléchisse à un meilleur
financement de la formation des salariés
les moins qualifiés des salariés les
plus modestes on a les outils pour ça on
a le compte personnel de formation par
exemple je suis pour qu'on l'Abonde euh
de manière un peu plus différenciée
suivant la qualification donant plus à
ceux qui en ont le plus besoin je suis
aussi pour je pense que Madame verzéti
sera d'accord avec moi là-dessus qui a
plus de dialogue social sur les enjeux
de formation aujourd'hui les
représentants des salariés n'ont pas
leur mot à dire en terme de négociation
sur la stratégie de formation de
l'entreprise on appelle ça le plan de
développement des compétences moi je
suis pour que ça devienne un enjeu de
négociation parce que c'est aussi comme
ça quand il y a de la présence syndicale
et des représentants du salarié qui
négocient aussi sur ces aspects là et
bien qu'on peut réduire les inégalités
d'accès à la formation et donc les
inégalités de salaire c'est une ver
làdus on va passer ça c'est c'est très
clair que nous on est favorable à à
pouvoir négocier sur plein d'autres
choses d'ailleurs vous avez dit sur la
formation sur les rémunérations bien
évidemment mais aussi et j'y reviens
parce que c'est important ça représente
des centaines de milliards d'euros je
l'ai dit sur l'utilisation des aides
publiques dans l'entreprise parce que
c'est quand même fort que l'employeur
puisse utiliser comme il le souhaite
sans euh rendre compte ni justement au
salariés ni à l'État ni à personne qui
ne rendent compte de l'utilisation de
ces centaines de milliards d'euros qui
sont versés comme ça par l'État et donc
c'est ce sont c'est de l'argent public
donc ça c'est une première chose et
c'est ce qu'on demande quand on dit
conditionnalité des aides publiques
c'est aussi un regard donc des
personnels des représentants des
personnels sur
l'utilisation de de cette somme d'argent
parce que c'est important puisquon nous
dit tout le temps il y a pas
suffisamment d'argent il y a pas
suffisamment de richesse pour augmenter
les salaires ou pour embaucher et bien
nous nous disons que non cet argent
existe mais finalement il n'est pas
utilisé correctement parce qu'il n'y a
pas de contrainte donné par l'État et le
gouvernement alors que ça devrait être
sa responsabilité puisque je le rappelle
c'est de l'argent public donc finalement
il y a nombre d'entreprises qui sont
sous perfusion sans aucune contrepartie
contrepartie qu'on ne se gêne pas de
demander à tous les privés d'emploi à
ceux qui ont un RSA et à tous les
salariés ou je je vous laisse répondre
làessus après on parle de la question
des plus
touours aux entreprises moi je vous ai
dit ce que j'en pensais tout à l'heure
pense qu'il faut les évaluer et quand on
les évalue correctement on se rend
compte que certaines ne sont pas
suffisamment efficaces on propose de les
supprimer donc nous on est assz à l'aise
avec
ça si vous permettez dans les aides dans
les aides il y a pas que des
exonérations il y a aussi des
subventions moi je m'occupais dans une
vie antériure plan de relance du plan
France relance là il y a des aides à
l'investissement don la contrepartie
c'est très clair pour une entreprise
c'est de réaliser un projet
d'investissement vous allez pas lui
demander en plus et bien d'atteindre un
certain nombre d'objectifs elle fait son
projet elle a une aide à un moment quand
on comptabilise les aides il y a ça à
prendre en compte aussi et donc les
contreparties elles existe beaucoup plus
que vous ce que ce que vous imagine sur
les 75 milliards d'euros non sur donc
c'est pas 200 milliards
c'est même ch il y a une autre question
qui été abordé hier c'est le salaire
minimum qui dans certaines branches est
inférieur au SMIC Alex d'AB pourquoi
alors comment ça s'explique et bien tout
simplement parce que le SMIC est indexé
sur l'inflation et vu l'ampleur de la
hausse des prix ces dernières années le
SMIC en France a souvent augmenté
dernière hausse en date en mai dernier
portant le SMIC à 1383 € nette mensuel
c'est-à-dire une hausse de 6 % sur 6 ans
et comme le SMIC augmente plus vite que
le reste des salaires certains salairire
minimum de branche se retrouve en
dessous de ce seuil national en mai
dernier 147 branches avaient un salaire
minimum inférieur au SMIC ce chiffre
actuellement se trouve à 60 branches he
selon le ministre du Travail Olivier dus
SOP mais cela ne veut pas dire qu'en
réalité les salariés des branches
concernées vont être payés en dessous du
SMIC car l'employeur se doit légalement
de combler cet écart en revanche cela
entraîne une concentration un tassement
des salaires autour du SMIC et justement
on va écouter la réponse hier
d'éliisabeth borne à cette
problématique si nous ne constatons pas
de progrès significatif d'ici le 1er
juin 2024
le gouvernement proposera au Parlement
un texte de loi qui permettra de
calculer les exonérations non pas sur la
base du SMIC mais sur la base du minima
de branche est-ce que c'est la bonne
réponse cers ah bien non parce que nous
justement on attend les des réponses
urgentes là parce que vous l'avez dit en
attendant les les salariés les privés
d'emploi tout ce qui ont du mal à à
vivre c'est maintenant qu'il demandent
et qu'ils ont besoin de mesures urgentes
comment se fait-il qu'il y a justement
des entreprises qui ne payent pas leur
salariés au SMIC alors que c'est une
obligation que c'est le droit et et
qu'il n'y a pas de de répon ben non
c'est ce n'est absolument pas normal
qu'il y ait des salariés payés en
dessous du SMIC et que la seule réponse
donc d'Élisabeth Bourne c'est de dire on
va attendre de voir ce qui va se passer
en juin 2024 et
éventuellement si cela perdure on on on
il y aura pas tout à fait on baissera
les exonérations de cotisation on n
annulera pas les exonérations de
cotisation on baissera les exonérations
de cotisation un minima de branche en
dessous du SMIC ne signifie pas que les
salariés de cette branche sont payés en
dessous du SMIC non sérieusement si on
peut pas se mettre d'accord sur ce
constat de base moi je peux vous dire
qu'il y a des salariés qui ne payent qui
ben non mais si il y a des salariés les
apprentis sont payés en dessous du SMIC
les salariés dans les aates les
établissements qui traitent les
personnes en situation de handicap sont
payés en dessous du SMIC mais parce que
ce sont des situations très
particulières quand vous avez un minima
de branche en dessous du SMIC ça
signifie quoi ça signifie pas que les
salariés sont payés en dessous du SMIC
ça signifie qu'il y a beaucoup de
salariés dont les qualifications sont
les mêmes euh don les qualifications ne
sont pas les mêmes justement qui ont le
même salaire et ça c'est un problème moi
je suis d'accord c'est ce qu'on appelle
vous le disiez tout à l'heure le
tassement des salaires le tassement des
Sal et ça c'est un problème et ça c'est
un problème et ça il faut s'y attaquer
maintenant combien de branches sont
concernées c'est pas 60 en réalité qui
sont concernés de manière durable c'est
plutôt une dizaine c'est ce qu'a dit
Olivier dus sopt parce qu'il y a des
branches qui sont en train de négocier
et qui vont bientôt atterrir sur leur
négociation et qui vont relever leur
minima donc il faut quand même voir ce
qu est l'ampleur du problème c'est
plutôt une 5 mais mais il y a une
dizaine de branches qui sont depuis plus
d'un an durablement dans une situation
où les minimas sont en dessous et
cellees-là je suis d'accord qu' il faut
leur mettre une pression supplémentaire
est-ce que c'est la bonne solution qui a
été proposée moi j'avoue que je suis un
peu circonspect sur cette idée sur cette
idée et bien de conditionner alors même
si c'est pas une conditionnalité stricte
c'est-à-dire que vous allez pas
supprimer toutes les exonérations mais
vous allez en disant que vous calculez
les exonérations non pas sur le SMIC
mais sur les minimas effectivement si
vous avez des minimas en dessous du SMIC
bah vous aurez moins d'exonération c'est
mécanique euh vous vous allez forcément
générer beaucoup beaucoup de complexité
et une des conclusions à laquelle nous
sommes parvenus avec mon collègue Jérôme
g dans ce rapport c'est que il faut
éviter de créer des usines à gaz qui
sont inapplicables je vous donne un
exemple parce que dans le droit il y a
une loi qui aujourd'hui prévoit déjà que
les entreprise de manière individuelle
puissent voir leurs exonérations
modulées lorsqu'elles ne négocient pas
assez dans les salaires c'est une loi
qui date de 2008ah figurez-vous qu'on a
fait dans le cadre de notre mission un
bilan de cette loi cette loi elle n'a
produit aucun effet elle a concerné
quelques dizaines d'entreprises quelques
dizaines de millions d'euros par rapport
aux dizaines de milliards qui sont
concernés par les exonérations et ça
montre quoi ça montre que c'est très
compliqué d'agir comme ça à l'échelle de
l'entreprise et à forcerie quand les
entreprises ont des comportements
différents à l'intérieur d'une même
ranche je pense que on va au- devant
d'un certain nombrebre de difficultés
juridiques et opérationnelles non mais
là il y a deux choses différentes il y a
en effet ceux qui sont quand même
rémunérés en dessous du SPIC et ceux
comme vous le dites qui finalement ont
une stagnation de leur déroulé de
carrière de leur évolution de
rémunération parce que il n'y a pas ce
que nous nous souhaitons et ce que nous
revendiquons par exemple justement
l'indexation des salaires par rapport au
niveau de la vie parce que cette
indexation permettrait automatiquement
comme c'est le cas pour le SMIC on le
sait c'est le code du travail qui
prévoit que le SMIC en fonction de
l'inflation augmente automatiquement
lorsqu'il y a une inflation bon je pas
je vais pas aller sur sur le calcul
précis mais ce n'est que le niveau du
SMIC qui qui augmente et pas le reste
donc des salaires et on s'aperçoit que
bien évidemment si vous n'augmentez pas
les autres rémunérations qui sont
au-dessus du SMIC et bien oui ce que
vous dites c'est en effet vrai
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a un tassement des
grilles tassement des grilles ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que vous avez des
salariés qui vont gagner exactement la
même chose pendant des années à des
années quoi que quel que soit leur
expérience leurs compétences et leurs
qualifications qui augmente normalement
avec le temps et la
formation problème n reste minut est-ce
que vous vous dites que cette conférence
sociale hier a quand même été utile sur
cette question du salaire et donc du
pouvoir d'achat des alors nous ce qu'on
dit c'est que cette conférence social ne
répond pas aux besoins urgents en
matière de pouvoir d'achat pour les
salariés puisqu'il n'y a aucune
augmentation générale qui a été annoncée
et qu'il n'y a pas de mesures
véritablement contraignante pour obliger
les entreprises d'une part à relever
tous les minimas qui sont en dessous
donc du SMIC qu'il n'y a pas de mesures
contre contraignante parce qu'il y avait
plusieurs sujets sur la question de
l'égalité professionnelle femme homme et
qu'il n'y a pas non plus de mesures
contraignantes par rapport au contrat
court et par rapport au temps partiel
imposé qui est donc utilisé abusivement
il n'y a donc aucune mesure
contreignante et pas non plus de
conditionnalité vis-à-vis des AES
publquesà déjà s'il y avait eu des
annonces fermes et définitives qui
soient sortis de cette conférence on
nous aurait dit on aurait dit au
gouvernement tout était déjà ficelé on a
négocié alors que vous aviez déjà pris
vos décisions pour non en méthode trouve
pas je trouve pas je trouve pas anormal
que on ouvre des chantiers si vous
permettez je vous ai laissé parler euh
qu'on ouvre des chantiers et qu'on dise
voilà ce qu'on va faire dans les
prochaines semaines et les prochains
mois c'est pas dans les prochaines
années ça va venir beaucoup plus vite
maintenant sur ce sur ce sujet non pas
d'augmentation général et indifférencié
des salaires on l'assume on l'assume
parce que on n pas envie de mettre des
centaines de milliers de personnes au
chômage c'est aussi simple que ça c'est
aussi simple que ça et on ne reviendra
pas là-dessus on a un esprit de
responsabilité depuis 2017 c'est la
raison pour laquelle on a créé 2
millions d'emplois et que le chômage est
passé de 9 et dem à 7
%itensite sur les contat cours sur les
cont contrat cours moi j'aurais aimé un
petit peu plus de soutien y compris
certaines organisations syndicales quand
et j'en étais un des architectes on a
mis en place un bonus malus pour les
entreprises qui surutilisent les contrat
courours qui pénalise les entreprises
qui utilisent beaucoup les CDD et qui et
qui donneent un bonus à celles qui les
utilise pas beaucoup donc je pense que
il y a des il y a des outils il y a des
leviers moi je vous suggère et je vous
propose d'en parler dans les prochaines
semaines mais à un moment un autre on ne
peut pas dire qu'on a rien fait on a une
ligne et une cohérence c'est de ne pas
détruire de l'emploi et rendez-vous est
pris on espère vous reviendrez en débat
sur ce plateau merci d'avoir été avec
nous avant de se quitter on regarde ce
qui a la une de nos quotidiens
[Musique]
régionaux et Alex on commence par l'Est
républicain qui a fait sa Une sur
l'attentat de Bruxelles oui un homme a
tué hier soir deux supporters suédois à
Bruxelles alors que se jouit le match de
football Belgique Suède dans la capitale
belge l'attaque s'est déroulé dans les
quartiers nord de la ville le suspect
âgé de 45 ans d'origine tunisienne qui
était ce matin toujours recherché et lié
au groupe état islamique et a revendiqué
cet attentat les les deux victimes ont
été ciblées parce qu'elles étaient
suédoises et cet attentat est sans doute
lié à une affaire de profanation de
corant en Suède cet été 3 jours après
l'attaque d'aras c'était le temps de
l'hommage hier à Dominique Bernard et
c'est la Une de beaucoup de nos
quotidiens régionaux oui c'est à la Une
de quasiment tous les journaux régionaux
ce matin les collégiens et les lycéens
ont observé une minute de silence hier
en hommage à Dominique Bernard
professeur tué par le terroriste haras
vendredi haras d'ailleurs les
professeurs se sont rassemblés devant la
préfecture l'intersyndical des
personnels de l'éducation a exprimé je
cite leur peine mais aussi leur fierté
de travailler auprès des élèves de les
aider de les protéger et de contribuer à
leur bonheur et à leur liberté et dans
le lycée Gambetta d'Arras où a lieu le
drame et bien le retour dans
l'établissement était compliqué hier
pour les élèves c'était à la Une c'est à
la une ce matin de de la voix du Nord
plusieurs élèves sont arrivés avec une
rose blanche à la main pour rendre
hommage à leurs professeurs après le
temps de l'émotion vient le temps des
questions notamment pour mieux protéger
lespreu oui c'est une question qui est
posée aujourd'hui à la Une du journal Le
Midi Libre le gouvernement réfléchit à
de nouvelles mesures pour protéger les
professeur Gabriel Atal le ministre de
de l'éducation nationale a notamment
évoqué et bien une actualisation de la
formation au premier secours un
renforcement des moyens humains en terme
de sécurité et une formation spécifique
de certains personnels dans ce genre
d'attaque les enseignants ont aussi eu
des idées ont aussi des idées sur ce
sujet un prof de sport d'un collège
parisien a par exemple échangé hier avec
le ministre et il propose de créer dans
chaque établissement scolaire une salle
avec quelques moyens de défense en cas
d'attaque comme par exemple du gaz
larymogène ce serait déjà ça mais
l'objectif n'est pas que l'école
devienne un un bunker tempère une
professeur dans un collège du gare qui
est interrogé par Midi Libre je la cite
he on sait que la meilleure de tout de
toutes les armes cela reste l'éducation
on termine rapidement avec le journal
L'Indépendant qui fait le portrait d'un
des hommes soupçonnés d'avoir incité le
terroriste d'aras à passer à l'acte oui
le journal catalan fait le portrait de
Maxime châauuf soupçonné par les
enquêteurs d'avoir radicaliser Mohamed
mogoukov avant son attentat maxime
châauuf est âgé de 32 ans cela fait 11
ans qu'il est en prison à l'âge de 17
ans ce père pignanet a perdu sa mère et
tombe dans la délinquence il a été
emprisonné pour un braquage de commerce
avant de se convertir à l'islam de se
radicaliser et d'être jugé pour
participation à une entreprise
terroriste c'était l'an dernier merci
Alex merci Marc Ferraci
merciti d'être venu pour ce débat merci
à tous de nous avoir suivi à 18h vous
avez rendez-vous avec Thomas pour s
public nous on se retrouve demain très
bonne
journée